[Music]
each time you take a step 200 muscles
work in unison to lift your foot propel
it forward and set it down it's just one
of the many thousands of tasks performed
by the muscular system this network of
over 650 muscles covers the body and is
the reason we can blink smile run jump
and stand upright it's even responsible
for the hearts dependable thump first
what exactly is the muscular system it's
made up of three main muscle types
skeletal muscle which attaches via
tendons to our bones cardiac muscle
which is only found in the heart and
smooth muscle which lines the blood
vessels and certain organs like the
intestine and uterus
all three types are made up of muscle
cells also known as fibers bundled
tightly together these bundles receive
signals from the nervous system that
contract the fibers which in turn
generates force in motion
this produces almost all the movements
we make some of the only parts of the
body whose motions aren't governed by
the muscular system are sperm cells the
hair like cilia in our Airways and
certain white blood cells muscle
contraction can be split into three main
types the first two shortening muscle
fibers and lengthening them generate
opposing forces so the biceps will
shorten while the triceps will lengthen
or relax pulling up the arm and making
it bend at the elbow this allows us to
say pick up a book or if the muscle
relationship is reversed put it down
this complementary partnership exists
throughout the muscular system
the third type of contraction creates a
stabilizing force in these cases the
muscle fibers don't change in length but
instead keep the muscles rigid this
allows us to grip a mug of coffee or
lean against a wall it also maintains
our posture by holding us upright
skeletal muscles form the bulk of the
muscular system make up about 30 to 40%
of the body's weight and generate most
of its motion some muscles are familiar
to us like the pectorals and the biceps
others may be less so like the Bucks
inator a muscle that attaches your cheek
to your teeth where the body's tiniest
skeletal muscle a one millimetre long
tissue fragment called the stapedius
that's nestled deep inside the ear
wherever they occur skeletal muscles are
connected to the somatic nervous system
which gives us almost complete control
over their movements this muscle group
also contains two types of muscle fibers
to refine our motions even further slow
twitch and fast twitch fast twitch
fibres react instantly when triggered
but quickly use up their energy and tire
up slow twitch fibers on the other hand
our endurance cells they react and use
energy slowly so they can work for
longer periods a sprinter will
accumulate more fast twitch muscles in
her legs through continuous practice
enabling her to quickly if briefly pick
up the pace whereas back muscles contain
more slow twitch muscles to maintain
your posture all day
unlike the skeletal muscles the body's
cardiac and smooth muscles are managed
by the autonomic nervous system beyond
our direct control that makes your heart
thump roughly three billion times over
the course of your life which supplies
the body with blood and oxygen autonomic
control also contracts and relaxes
smooth muscle in a rhythmic cycle that
pumps blood through the smooth internal
walls of blood vessels enables the
intestine to constrict and push food
through the digestive system and allows
the uterus to contract when a person is
giving birth
as muscles work they also use energy and
produce an important by-product heat in
fact muscle provides about eighty-five
percent of your warmth which the heart
and blood vessels then spread evenly
across the body via the blood without
that we couldn't maintain the
temperature necessary for our survival
the muscular system may be largely
invisible to us but it leaves its mark
on almost everything we do whether it's
the blink of an eye or a race to the
finish line
this video is made possible by our
community on patreon and if you're
curious about the human body check out
this playlist
[Music]